عن اي اتفاق نتحدث نقرا في موقع اكسيوس ان
المقترح الجديد لوقف اطلاق النار المقدمه
الى كل من اسرائيل والجهاد الاسلامي يختلف
في صيغته عن المقترح السابق ولا تفاصيل
اكثر لكن بغض الطرف عن التفاصيل فحديث
الساعه المحتوم عن التطبيق على الارض
يتساءل متابعون للمشهد الله منذ ايام عن
طرق تثبيت وقف اطلاق النار
ليس معروفا ايضا كيف سيتم التاكد من
التزام الجانبين بما ورد في نص اتفاقهما
وهل تمت اليه واضحه لذلك لا يبدو الامر
يسيرا بالنظر الى الفتره التي استغرقتها
جهود ومحاولات التوصل لتهدئه هل الامر
مختلف هذه المره قد لا يتوافق هذا التوجه
مع نهج التصعيد العسكري الذي اطلقه
الاحتلال في قطاع غزه دون مبرر الامنيين
مباشر بل مع تلويحه المستمر كذلك بنقل
المواجهه الى مستويات اخرى لكن ابرام
اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار لا يمكن فصله عن
المشهد السياسي والامني في الداخل
الاسرائيلي
ثم تضغوط مورست لا شك على ائتلاف نتنياهو
اليميني كي يضع حدا لما بدا في البدء حتى
في نظر المعارضه الاسرائيليه عمليه صحيحه
وناجحه لكنها ابانت مع الوقت عن كلاف
باهظه لا احد في اسرائيل مستعد كما يبدو
للاستمرار في دفعها ربما كانت الصعيد في
غزه واستئناف عمليات اغتيال قاده المقاومه
رضوحا من نتنياهو لعوتات المتطرفين في
حكومته بما يحفظ تماسكها وربما ساعه حقا
لترميم قوه ردع اسرائيل الاخذه في التاكل
لكن محللين في اسرائيل يرجحون الا تكون
مكاسب نتنياهو من خطوته على قدر توقعاته
فلا يبرا من كل متاعبه الداخليه من خلال
تغيب الاجنده الامنيه وتصدير ازماته
الداخليه بل تجده في المقابل مدفوعا من
النخب السياسيه والاعلاميه وحتى من الشارع
لانهاء التصعيد العسكري
الاكثر نقبه المتاثرين في مستوطنات غلاف
غزه من رد المقاومه القوي والمنسق وكذا
المستشعرين للاعباء الاقتصاديه المتولده
عن التصعيد ولخسائر اخرى اكبر قد
يتكبدونها اذا طالت المواجهه او اتسعت
رقعتها حكومه نتنياهو الائتلافيه احرص من
هؤلاء جميعا كما يبدو على تلف حرب من ذلك
القبيل